I actually to be totally recursive about
it I just wrote a couple of blogs about
why I blogged I did it initially because
I just wanted to sort of feel what it
was like I've always had this belief and
this is what I wrote the first of the
two blogs on that they're really two
ways to learn things one is in a more
sort of school like atmosphere which is
a you know somebody with more
information imparts that information to
you whether in a classroom or via a book
or if you're grown up in the business
world you go out and you hire McKinsey
and they write you a hundred page
beautiful report on the social
phenomenon an economic model of blogging
and social media you read it you
underline a bit you think you pay too
much but for that moment you sort of
feel like you get it but you don't
really know the contours because you've
just essentially read somebody else's
work you you're not able to integrate
that into your worldview the other way
of doing it and it's so simple you know
I couldn't go out and wouldn't want to
go out and build a nuclear bomb but it
isn't that hard to go out to any one of
the various sites and create your own
blog and do it and interact with people
and see what people are interested in
and how do you post comments and how do
you review them and how do you sort of
incorporate that into your into your
next work and so I just started doing it
to learn by doing and then along the way
I discovered actually I liked it I was
gonna do it in a different way than
let's say traditional if one could even
say there's such a thing as traditional
blogging so so young in its in its life
but most bloggers who are professional
bloggers are doing it almost with
Twitter rapidity you know multiple posts
a day because they're trying to drive
traffic and people are supposed to come
look at it and obviously if you only
once every couple of weeks you're not
gonna have much to monetize advertising
against but I'm not doing it for that
purpose so I only write when there's a
intersection of a when I have time and B
when I feel I have something to say and
I don't have I don't feel I have
something to say more than once or twice
a month so that's how I evolved into the
current position